[Music]
hi how's it going hope you're having a
great day so I've heard a little bit of
a delay
so today I we did this kind of like cute
poll on what to do right
so the strategy games had a better more
of a more desirable
there's my choice of word of the day
there we go and so I kind of tried to
find something that had a combination of
both
so both a little bit strategic some set
time tactic involved so I hope this game
will fulfill the both of these sides so
another thing that I wanted to mention
was to during this week on Tuesday for
the chess and psychology we talked about
should we always castle or not so this
game kind of follows that idea as well
so you get to question your knowledge
about castle if you wanted to castle
again or you don't want a castle so
those are the ideas and all right so
without further ado let's start so this
is a game between Huisman and Carlsen
2008 so if you remember the last game
that I showed you about the the castle
question was also a game that Carlson
played so I mean you see the connection
right doesn't like to Castle huh I'm
kidding he he's a great player he
obviously knows more about went to
castle and not to castle so oh all right
well let's start yeah thank you
Venn diagram all right so let's start
this game was specifically interesting
for me because I got to see the openings
that I play so I do play this eg xb6 the
Queen's Indian
and so I usually play it with Bishop d7
but in this game they played it at
Bishop a6 which I thought is
specifically interesting because after
Bishop i6 there are a lot of ideas like
with Bishop b4 if I remember correctly
this idea is with Bishop a sings on
Bishop before have also been played a
lot in the Karpov Kasparov matches so if
you guys know more about that feel free
to share and let me know as well so
looking at this position you kind of
already have a idea like okay so 93 is
off the board because the c4 pawn is
weak so Bishop d2 or 92 right so oh yeah
thank you
b15 I don't think this is called book
going down but it does follow because
boku Indian was the one that like this
the bishop before check then comes back
to e7 night so you're not necessarily
doing that right now and I mean you can
definitely but it's it's a little bit
different because that could the book
Indian could also be played with d5 but
yes this is the similar idea thank you
for sharing that I'll keep all right so
after Bishop d2 there's different
choices
I believe c5 is one of their moves yep
it does transpose is your correct Bishop
e7 is another one of their moves taking
as a move but I'm not doing it's one of
taking because if you take just take
back with the night and next move easy
for coming you know I don't really like
that as for black so that's why we think
about Bishop e7 so this would be 7 we
can start to realize a pattern so we
kept we decided to keep the Bishop
because we are also trying to delay this
Knight c3 because what with Knight c3
this pawn is falling right so another
thing that we can realize is we can
start thinking about D files and C fives
so those are another set of
that black is comfortable trying to play
alright yeah
so after visually seven I think
efore is the move that is most worrisome
because if Bishop g2 alright it is
attacking my well it's kind of looking
at this direction but we can't just wrap
it up with a defense right so after E
for mm I it's kind of obvious we also
still do have to play d5 because if not
then then e five is coming and then if
whenever you play d5 there's gonna be
someone Pisans there's it's not very
pleasant
also if you cast off after E 5 what do
you want to do with your night go to yet
what is just Bishop d3 this is already
get it getting a little crunchy alright
so after E 4 we gotta play this d5 right
so d5 now my first question to the
audience as white if you take over here
you are gonna lose your chance to castle
so as white do you want what do you want
to do do you want to take on d5 or are
you going to just ignore the pawn on d5
pushy 5 what do you want to do
other things to consider is well you
can't necessarily just go play Bishop g2
now because c4 and you are falling so
you have to kind of just play it a
little more aggressive ct5 yeah Syd if I
wouldn't do after Bishop a fondo you can
also consider eat d5 but 85 just 85 and
then this is the same problem again what
do you want to do with this pawn b5 is
interesting what I think a5 what do you
do after nice efore hmm yeah so those
are some questions to consider I thank
you guys for participating yeah see d5
in this position is actually okay it's
playable and city fives idea is pretty
pretty obvious take you want to take it
with the king and yes King g2 is coming
up next so good you guys know your
theory huh so you got to take back now
e5 Knight e4 is pretty straightforward
right because if ninety seven and this
just doesn't really make sense to me 94
93 take take now blacks you move how do
you want to continue do you want to
start pushing like c5 do you want to
castle do you want to bring out some
pieces what do you want to do
Casta large castle is definitely
interesting there are better moves - you
do have a little bit more like sneaky
moves I guess we can call it let me ask
you where do you want this night to be
yeah okay you want the night to be on
the kingside I agree with that
I'm Annie but how like can you give me a
specific square like ideally also
realistically cuz ideally I one night in
c4 or and E for but all right so 97 but
97 is not really going anywhere
me technically are supporting c5 but si
clock doesn't need to be supported oh I
like the idea of bringing in the Queen
good job so we are talking about Queen
c8 maybe a six
what about Queen d7 yeah 97 98 is too
slow but I like your idea what wanting
the knight to be on to e6 so night on e6
is the best realistic position it covers
the King side a little bit it covers the
Queen side a little bit it's in the
center almost so I think 96 is the best
place for the night to be right so in
order to achieve that we could do this
but it really stops whoa so many years
but it really stops our castling or
delays it's another way to do it is to
do this Queen d7 we are threatening
Queen your street check so King g2 is
pretty forced now we get to bring out
knight c6 now we want to do this
yep 96 98 you're correct
I'm any also a thank you for saying
Queen d7 Ally vision Samim oh I think I
actually pronounce that right whoa you
guys want to have horrible horrible with
pronunciations so yeah
okay so 96 your ideas - pretty clear you
want to buy 98 you want to play 96 you
want to keep that night in the right
spots and then start developing your
looks and start pushing for see five or
so right so in this position let's say
white boys see four now what do you want
to do are you gonna cast though are you
gonna follow up with the 98 plan what
are you gonna do
one that's really getting suggestion now
am i you guys are thinking whoa let me
try and give you a little bit of hint we
don't really want to Castle right now
mainly because if we cast all I like 98
more I'm a little worried to Castle
because now you're giving well you see
white king is safe but your King is like
it has a big target on it see why it's
gonna just start marching on right so I
kind of don't want to allow that and
that is why we would ideally try and
avoid having that h4 h5 h6 happen to us
right so it's the it's kind of better to
just wait a little bit and then decide
what to do with the King we also don't
want long castle because they're already
open like already open ish files on like
Biggie and and CDPH I don't know so it's
best to just play 98 if you might see
the dc4 it's also not a good idea
because take and then d4 is coming out
d5 is coming up just like a huge deal in
the center so good job on thinking so
it's the best idea to just go with 98
first and after you play 98 now you get
the chance to actually bring that night
to e6 and start pushing for possible
opening up the center right so after 98
who's my flight C takes d5 and now we
play Queen takes d5 right because you
die mean you you got to take that pawn
back you can't just sit around and wait
er wait at it taking on c7 is not a good
idea right now cuz well there is 96
followed by 94 and this might is pent
right so let's not do that
let's say queen a4 check now what do you
want to do do you want b5 you want c6
you want King f8 black to move what do
you want to do also I kind of just
realized that's a little bit off topic
what while you guys are thinking about
what to do for black Alexander Huisman
is this Israeli player that's my brother
played with back in Gibraltar 2017 and
the hell broke loose then that's kind of
it's just like I when I was looking at
the game I just was looking at the game
I didn't really look at the players so
it's kind of fun not fun maybe ironic
yeah let's go with ironic that I kind of
just picked this alright so I okay let's
crash Queen d7 and Queen C sixes because
this is a good position for black black
is kind of this queen is doing some good
useful stuff you are keeping these pawns
intact and if you play Queen c6 what if
take take and then d5 right then what
are you gonna do with your night go to
a5 that's kind of weird especially 5 you
got to kind of go all the way back I
mean it's not worth it so come on Quincy
six I agree
same with the Queen d7 take take T five
King f8 I think you can still fight a
little about where to put the king so
you can just go with c6 I really like c6
c six is very stable you are just having
it I mean just kind of chillin over here
you don't know what you want to do with
your King yet but you do know you want
to get this night on e6 right so it's
like let's I really like the c6 idea
maybe yeah b5 possible I think b5 is a
little too aggressive because if B 5
let's say white goes queen bee tree
wants to trade Queens for just just an
example
then your pawn is always a little behind
and c-5s are getting harder and harder
every move and when you play like c6
it's always gonna be weaknesses but I'm
just brainstorming right now I mean
Queen b3 as Y as black you don't really
have to take it so there's that all
right so after c6 rook c1 yeah Brucie 1
what do you think you should do with
black well right now a knight c6 doesn't
work you can't really touch the strip
because of a 7 pawn so what do you want
to do castling is I guess technically
possible but kind of takes the fun away
right
I'm not the biggest fan of castles b5
it's still a big maybe but everything is
beef I was a huge commitment and I don't
know if the position is ready for that
not like my queen I don't want a sec it
also that wouldn't be a sacrifice it's
with Peters no mistake and a blunder
that's also something I realized a lot
of the kids in my classes say that like
let's the boots do the sacrifice what
sacrifice is something good right it's
like a noble sacrifice for greater good
or something like that but something
like this blundering the Queen it's just
like blundering the Queen okay
I also Dan I know you were joking just
felt like sharing my philosophy behind a
sacrifice married okay g5 whoa nature
six alright so from what I see in the
chat we started from thinking about a 6
B 5 stuff like that and now we've moved
to the other side you're talking about
g5h sixes and that's kind of cool um
alright so I don't think any of you guys
have said this move oh wait no once
someone said it oh no all right you are
correct Darrin if you've seen this game
well good job when remembering it if you
have not well excellent job on thinking
about it same for you chess King okay so
oh hold on now we can't just play 96 now
the c6 pawn is on wobbly right
I mean Queen c6 also so let's not lose
okay what opening is this ASA
how did this opening is version of
Queen's Indian the the one with b6
special a suspicious before then bring
it back we could call that BOGO Indian -
okay so the point of King t7 is yeah it
is very risky but you kind of want to
hold on let me find the right word to
say because I was gonna say get your
inner child out and then I was thinking
you're bringing the King out it's solid
protects upon that is correct but not
necessarily the thing is when you play
King t7 and then you play 96 your knight
is blocking the center so it is kind of
impossible for white to break it out
also the problem is if you were to cast
whoops if you were to castle right now
then how are you gonna get get this 96
I'll just start doubling these rooks up
stack them up together and you're gonna
lose this pawn ok let's go back a little
after King g7 so another so if King t7 I
think another another move to consider
like a second best move to consider was
Ruka was a 5 with the idea rook c8
because we couldn't play rook c8 they
move before a7 is under attack right so
a5 but the problem is with Queen b3
because if you take take the 10 you are
going to just White has like it it's not
unpleasant endgame for black or white
has better chance to better chances of
well just putting more pressure
so after Castle c5 is possible but c5
you're going to ruin your own pawn
structure and I wouldn't recommend that
I wouldn't want that for myself I
wouldn't wish that on any of my friends
all right
so King e7 we could think about a 6 but
take maybe 95 if possible right would be
cool right if this was possible but
legally we have a little bit of the
pinned issue but yeah I was just
thinking if not a 5 as possible then
King then King t7 is not worth it
so ok I'm gonna just do a little bit of
like hypothesis let's say okay just
gonna do a bad move because I want to
show you the e6
say it is what was the code was it this
yeah I remember it let's say it is nope
I just gave another move to whites
that's not what I wanted to do oh boy ah
I missed it all right let's go back it's
not what I want
let's say it's the King goes back here
and that is wise to move whoa sorry I
forgot my chest base commands there we
go
now let's say it's white to move again
white can do this ecigs and then can do
this 95 right now this position is very
pleasant for whites you get the c6
attack you're just under check what are
you gonna do King d8 steak back here is
this horrible I don't want to look at
this position we all agree this is a
pretty horrible position so King g7 is
also good because the c6 95 doesn't
exist so in the game Guzman played
Bishop b4 with idea to just try and poke
some holes in blacks position because if
you are just going to sit around and
watch as white next move it's 96 coming
and then everything is super stable so
thank you taking two turns yeah I would
like that too but so Bishop before now
it's black to move what do you think oh
I can do [ __ ] like take on before
should I just ignore it and maybe just
play rook e8 defend my work should i
play like b5 attack the Queen yeah just
let me know what are you thinking
basically blacks you move what to do
ah Roxy for I don't know what are you
talking about also because it's back to
me takes takes 96 hmm that's interesting
[Music]
well I think the main question is do you
need to take it right now or can you
like push some pawns
yeah I think you're correct
Anand see varam yeah so I see it the
moves for the next few moves on here
right now okay you're good punished yeah
Lucy for was possible but what I mean b5
it sounds like a blunder no alright um
so Bishop before what we can do is we
can simply just take a play b5 take
there and push on a5 so exactly we're
doing the pushy pushy style so a5 Queen
b3 now we get this Knight to e6 so this
is a very ideal setup and we can't
imagine let's just think about take take
so in this position what do you think
who do you think is better do you want
to be white or black maybe give me a
small reasoning sure I can't call it
Krishna
so yeah black should be better right
because you have that pawn majority you
can start pushing on the queenside and
it's gonna give you some serious
advantage right the King sign is kind of
hard to start pushing it for whites but
the Queen side is kind of set to start
rolling right yeah all right so I'm I
guess you I'm glad you guys agree with
me on this
so go also like next few moves for black
would be to bring like rocks tarik c4
and just like show on the C file as well
yeah black better not winning thank you
yep all right let's go back
so that is why huisman did not take
Queen d5 after 96 he took her to a c6 do
you think this works because well if you
play like change takes c6 there's your
c1 right so do you think let me let me
ask you let me rephrase my question
black do you move what do you want to do
and please for the move that for the one
move that you give me please give me
what do you think is best for whites to
answer as your move to so if you're
telling me King takes c6 make sure you
mentioned rook see you want to I hope
you're gonna tell me I don't know when
you want to trade Queens ox ox L so if
you're giving me trade Queens if you're
giving me Queen takes me tree what do
you think white would do a takes b3 or
do you see any intermediate checks
so I'm Annie it's cool that you're
thinking about Forks but it doesn't work
cause Queen f3 Queen takes f3 yep Thank
You chess King Queen takes B 3 is wrong
because strict e6 check and then you got
to move your king and then your Queen
gets picked up so this is winning from
whites now this endgame with the pawns
oh boy
so we establish Queen B trees but they
talked about king c6 is horrible so you
kind of just gotta think about Queen c6
right d5 is pretty much the obvious move
see I told you strategy and some tactics
we got the cool King g7 strategy and we
got the cool
this tactic with drug c6 rook c8 doesn't
work you I'll be careful your queen
undefined is defenseless you gotta take
this now what if d5 why not king c6
because if you do king c6 always think
about checks guys checks checks checks
rook see one your queen is falling right
all right
oh that's interesting you're thinking
what might f4 check whoa Knight to f4
check take 10 Queen c6 I like this it's
very interesting what do you do if d5
Queen g6 maybe I think this is also
worth mentioning a little bit but the
problem is like if d5 Queen c4 it's
interesting but it's very similar to
just take t5 Queen c4 and the thing is
if take now you get the chance to take
this pawn back instead of having this
pawn just hang around here without the
night so in this position the waxing
move what do you want to take this pawn
with the pawn with the Queen you want to
ignore that phone what do you want to do
you want to play king of the hill
so I have it I have a taker for Queen
takes a six going once going twice
come on nobody wants King g6 all right
we have an Fe six on the Gores
what about King takes c6 we need chest
whip to come tell us to play king of the
hill more often huh
I think F takes c6 is also possible but
the problem is like rook d1 check and
I'm not really sure how what to do after
that so we have a lot of F takes c6 and
some Queen yeah okay so good job
thinking about King g6 very good
so King g6 you gotta think about what
your opponent's gonna do right otherwise
why wouldn't you do king g6 so King g6
good job thinking about Knights if nice
g4 check
so let's establish something if King
takes c6 Queen takes c4 the pawn takes
c4 this is good right you are whoops you
are in a better end game so I like that
so far so good
what if change takes is six Knight d4
what is the mating one because I don't
see you see it please let me know I
don't think there is a mate mate in one
exists now you're trolling me aren't you
alright so King e6 is the move to
actually sit down and think about
because if Knight if 94 well oh this is
such a good move hold on before we get
too deep in 94 let's look at the move
such as Queen III because if you play
Queen III then what do you think black
should do
ah king of the hill I got it now
thank you yeah
just we would love that maybe we should
change the title of this with you to how
to play king of the hill all right so
what do you want to do after King Queen
III I understand your desire to play
King d5 right now but be careful it's
just kind of chestnut king of the hill
and King D five you're gonna get
punished with something like rook t1 or
e six first you take the route big one
yeah good job so you want to bring the
rook in rook hc8
Isaiah 58 is also interesting but now
the poor the idea is so you are actually
threatening to go after the Queen so
let's say the Queen tries to run away
you still follow now you have all of
these central files you take over here I
can clean g6 I'm gonna hunt your Queen
down and start exchanging that on my
rooks are too strong my pawns are baby
Queens
all right so glad they agree on that
what about 94 let's get back to this 94
you wanna play king of the hill take on
e5 or play King defy or you want to go
back
in the specific position that we were
just talking about I do think route t8
also works but rook c8 is just better so
when you're suggesting you move like
king d5 maybe also give me a little bits
a little bit more like what do you think
White's gonna do like King t5 I guess
Queen f3 is the only check all the
reasonable check maybe let's look at
that
oh you want to take on e5 okay taking
about if I have a little scare you I
mean there's Queen d3 all right Mourad
us Thank You King be [ __ ] d5 if Queen
b5 take take it take the pawn on e5 yeah
that's good
also if King d5 Queen B 5 yeah I think
that's good enough I was thinking it was
King d4 but there's like oofty ones and
then there's like a bunch of other
checks coming like king e4 then your
queen on c4 is weak let's not do that
King g7 all right we have a tailor for
kingi 7 I think King g7 is also doable
but it's like we need more creativity in
chess guys Chingy 7 it's okay it's
playable but what if just I was thinking
about just Knight takes p5 if possible
if you exchange the coins okay now it's
a 90 and a pawn against riff it's not
that obvious who is doing like blacks
advantage is kind of getting questioned
right now also if Knight easier if King
G 7 there are other checks like 9 to 5
if you go up I can take that and just
keep repeating this whole thing if you
play like King FH then your rook is kind
of stuck now I can't start giving you
possible checks or go to f3 and hope for
a little bit more advantage on that side
I can't just want to be able to play a
little bit more creative instead of
kingly 7 King da is actually a very very
good idea with [ __ ] 5 yeah so King D 5
you kind of its like Genie 5 is one of
those moves that like when you play it's
also psychologically you are pressuring
your opponent's into making a mistake
into giving you some weird undesired
checks
something like that so in fact the mover
c6 sacrifice an exchange is not that
worth it right yep
you're completely correct I'm Annie
thank you so let's look at look back at
this position so after King d5 imagine
you're white your opponent just played
King t5 what do you want to do oh this
actually reminds me ha I was playing a
game today just like maybe an hour ago
on Twitch
for our channel and we actually there
was a game that actually my King was on
e6 I don't think I went off to d5 but I
was so ready to play King d5 I'm gonna
just talk about the opening you don't
need to visualize it if you do good the
opening was a 45 9 f3 knight c6 Bishop
c4 Bishop c5 so far Italian c3 Knight c6
d 4 take pawn takes back still normal
open Italian Bishop b4 check Bishop d2
here usually people take Bishop d2 I'm
not the biggest fan of that so I just
played 94 this is also theory if you
can't picture it that it's perfectly
fine but for those of you who can this
is also another like a little trick
Knight takes e4 Bishop takes d4 Knight
takes before the shove on c4 takes f7
check King takes f7 Queen b3 check
attacking the knight on d4 to d5 Knight
e5 check the King on f7 goes to e6 first
move Queen takes b4 now you can play c5
attacking the Queen on before attacking
the pawn on d4 and can't take back
because the knight on e5 is being
attacked by the King just wanted to
bring that up
feel free to scroll back a little bit
like go back and try to memorize
visualize it if you can that's perfectly
fine if you can feel free to send me
messages or comments and we can chat
about it later I just wanted to bring
that up that's I did something similar
to this King on e6 2
you lost me on the last month uh all
right now at this point I feel like it's
better to all right let's wrap this game
up when black wins if we still have time
I'll just show you that game okay I
guess that's a little better than trying
to repeat that again okay yeah
so after king d5 Queen f3 is best so my
problem with Queen b5 is um I I do think
taking you do have to take because if
you take here there's your key ones and
your queen is gonna be lost pretty soon
so you do have to take after Queen b5
but your pawn on c5 your pawn on e5 is
still falling so if I play something
like c8 so your knight can't go to c4
and c7 then be able to take on e5 it's
kind of like I also I already really
like black too so okay so after Queen b5
I think loom if I was a fair try for the
end game but the end game is gonna be
wearing their divorce and the other
thing is like when you play something
like King d5 your opponent's already
wants to expand Eshoo we're opponent
wants to show you that King d5 is
against chess rules you shouldn't bring
your king up right so yeah basically
thank you
thank you for mentioning that Krishna
all right so Queen f3 check now what do
you want to do with your king when I go
to king c5 you want to eat this you want
to eat that you want to try and promote
your king to a new king
so yeah what do you want to do after
Queen f3
I mean I guess you're a pretty committed
right if kinky for I don't think it's
worse there's so many different
variables in queen of for knight c6 come
on rookie one all right so let's not do
King g5 let's do King d4 so King Deford
the move that you have to worry about is
Queenie three because they first do you
want you can just go back and hide
behind your Queen rights no Roxy once no
checks nothing so you're good run to a6
basically at that point you would be
starting to run to a6 yeah you can take
the knight actually surprisingly but I
how why would you lose the Queen Oh are
we talking about the different position
if not in this position you can actually
take the ninth and you're perfectly fine
so that's like we need to recheck and
Queen III the best move well pretty much
the only move is King d5 right check you
don't be careful not to blunder and
stuff like that just put your king to e6
check come back check so here and you
gotta be a little bit careful right
because something like f6 there's Queen
g7 we don't want to deal with that
if you blunder King f8 there is a mate
coming up right you don't
I didn't get many trades it's gonna be
painful and it's not to that kingi 8 is
the best move
what about Queen 83 after King d5 the
key I mean you can just if queen a tree
what if just Rock d8 and then the king
would just go back to east 6 to answer
Sammy yep King Yale is pretty much the
only move so right now white played east
6 so it does look horribly the interest
for black right but it's not really that
it's not really the interest because you
do need to bring out your rooks true fun
facts it would be funny to Castle with
us illegal right
but all right so black to move how do
you want to bring out your pieces you
just need to be able to do a little bit
of more exchange and get some pieces out
and you will win this game because
you're a full workup
so what do you want to do
you do have kind of limited options
first of all don't want to take that
cousin Queen g7 and ouch
everywhere so Queenie for interesting
Queenie for you could try Queenie for
but then if you try to cover up your b5
phone is falling by Queenie for maybe
looking g1 depending on your next move
Queen B 5 is coming up I kind of don't
want to deal with that eat the pond and
f6 all of this either tank or f6 there's
Queen g7 attacking your Rick and
attacking Queen d7
ah you're good I'm a New York c8 yeah
now you see it you actually do have some
threats to you could potentially
consider some checks again potentially
because right now the Queen is defending
it but let's say take on f7 then you do
have to take with the Queen because if
you take with the King there is kt7 and
then Queen g7 right or if we nice Evan
depending on where the King goes oh
there was an interesting York a7 idea it
would work if like it works for the
seventh rank but it doesn't work for
your back rank so be careful with these
little tricks rook c8 take Queen tanks
so in the game like okay if I take just
King f8 it's right and there is no more
threats no more tracks no more real like
there no real threats rook d7 is okay
just keep the Queen around so in the
game husband plays rook d3 simple idea
we're capturing your key three want to
go after your king what do you want to
do as black
after it takes up seven and no you
couldn't because if he takes f7 let me
go back a second if you play King f8 the
rook th that's why you gotta take it to
the Queen rook t3 now ha Castle would be
fun though right castling would be a
great idea but it's illegal and Huisman
would stop the clock on the I return
telling you to put your King back and
now you would have to move with the King
King fi a trajectory tada
he'll lose so don't do this kind of
blunders Brooksie - there's d8 queen or
roommate don't do that
check on Queen b7 I like that always
check your opponent right rook f8 stroke
offense what about rook III I still
don't like that or even trick f8 Queen
takes me five for Queen f6 interesting
what about stroke III again you move the
king to that file there's your chemistry
so oh hi I remember you alpha from
chrome L was your name Oliver please let
the be Oliver otherwise
I owe you an apology but yes Queen b7 is
the best one thank you for participating
your kf8 is the problem intricate fate
is just a letter a lot of checks to
cover their is Queen e5 there's Queen B
5 it's just it's kind of hard to survive
this and it is best to give this check
make the King go away neither this wreck
f8 can you quick Queen f6 go king of 7
no because there is rook III check King
of 7 rook F 3 and the rook just like
picks your Queen up your queen gets
pinned so in order to actually save this
game and save your queen you do need to
have the two plates check King go away
Rick f8 now if we're he three
King can run away right can you can
chill chill go back there after a kf8
what about queen ash five check
Queenie five all soups not that I wanted
to go to e5 Queenie five not really
possible just Queenie seven are I guess
just King up seven also doable just
trying to run away
what about Queen h5 so you can't play
this King of seven anymore do you want
to try a queen up seven do you want to
try a trick up seven do you want to play
King g7 g6 I'm not really mentioning g6
because then check King f7 your king is
already getting super weak again or even
a g6 43 I don't really want that so let
me tell you the problem with rook F 7 is
what if I simply think about taking here
giving check nope
what if I just do I need to eat this
truck man how do I attack this truck
well Queen fives don't really work
anymore cuz it's just there what about
hmm drinking trees don't work cuz the
Queen takes right well then what is
wrong with your capsule
maybe maybe my first insect instinct was
right what if I take over here because
King evades don't really work again
I think the only the only thing to
actually be worried about this is yeah
maybe check and take or I mean Rick III
you can just go the other way too or
maybe like queen r7 right now to still
holds this check on g8 or rookie tree I
don't really see any like counter checks
I think both of them are good maybe Rick
III is actually better yeah rookie three
cuz if King t8 um now you don't really
need to screen your seven anymore you
could just give another check maybe get
away with a professional - yeah I think
Rick III and Queen are seven those are
the moves to play a free cup 7 clean up
7 doesn't work because clean up 7 what
did they say there was Queenie fiber key
3 probably I kept forgetting what we
said maybe Queenie five Queen d7 take on
b5
oh no there's King at 7 no there's Rick
Dees on all right I'm good
whoo there's that ball it all right so
that's the problem with Queen f7 Queenie
5 queen bee 547 the problem with G
sticks what is the problem with g6 I
want to say check and now the kink is
not safe but I need more than just that
I need a little bit more reasoning maybe
rook d6 weed idea recap 6 or Queen e6
but you just play King gh let's go a
little back
so if g6
okay g6 what to eats cannot eat over
here f king f7 I have a root 57 right
if Keeney seven now maybe I really want
to play this roof oh wait why am i
saying queen bee five sorry I just kept
in here with Queen f7 alright yeah I
guess it was fun to see me blunder the
existence of the Queen there haha
alright um I'm trying to figure out
what's wrong with juicy sorry its Queen
e5 the King just runs away so let's not
do that maybe a rookie three if the king
of sevens now there's queen of seven
right so you kind of got a player like
King d8 play it a little on the down low
and then maybe Queen g5 king c 7s or
always rook see it working silence yeah
I think that's the problem with it's
just cookie three and Queen g5 okay all
right sorry about my little brain freeze
alright so g6 is wrong because of rookie
three and then Queen g5 we're grabbed
seven doesn't work because I've just
takes on h7 or check first then take on
h7 Queen f7 doesn't work because of
Queenie five and then clean b5 and
they're drugged t7 yeah so now we've
eliminated all the other options but
King g7 so you gotta play King g7 now it
is white to move what do you think you
should do kind of they're all you have
limited checks right if you play Queen
e5 well just the King runs away so Queen
e5 is the opponent friendly move let's
not do that
what about rocketry rookie three it's
kind of forcing your hand to play King
d8 right huh thank you yeah poor girl
alright so King d8 I like this my king
is kind of safe over here what about
Rick t3 proposing a perpetual nope we
are a rook up with play king c7 can you
see seven you're kind of kind of safe
from chase right now if Queenie Phi
whoops that is a blunder I wanted 25 we
just do king b6
it's almost almost safe give me check I
ran away
alright just play your xe6 right so
almost safe so what else do you want to
do if not if not check on Queenie fiber
Queen c5
the only other move to try and get
something out of the position is your t5
because with your t5 you're attacking
you are taking away the King b6 idea
because of oops blunder and you now want
to give this check on Queenie five right
okay
so Brian I don't know where do you want
to play Queen d1 before right now
Queen d1 just I mean the problem is
check your King gets checked
otherwise there would be rocketing
through your rights hello Carter oh yeah
Queen d7 doesn't work because it's I
mean Queen d1 doesn't write because of
Queen d7 check and the tactic Queen so
you kind of force the Queen exchange but
nice idea okay so Rick t3 checking up
now rook t5 is the only move so you are
so so close to winning just need to get
this King to somewhere safe I leave my
king to be safe right
so we said Queen c5 doesn't work because
of Queen c6 you give check just King b8
also what if King just goes to d8 v8
sorry it's the king is safe okay so
after King did guys we just talked about
it
if King d8 queen d1 it doesn't work
because of Queen d7 check great thank
you
hope it clears it up remember whoops
check check
okay let's go back to roots III King c7
or
d5 the best move is to actually play
rook e8 I know it's a little too heavy
to understand but through he itu-r
covering both of these files so you're
taking away the Queen ePHI checks you're
also taking away the Queen f7 checks so
the only available check is Rick c5 rook
c5 be careful cuz King b6 or King b8 you
would be losing this pawn and your queen
after so we don't want that so you gotta
go back to the D file now there is only
one square that takes all the checks
away right d6 because if you play king
th there is a still check check check
so many checks or even like g5 chick
it's for check d1 okay d1 is still a
summer cause between 27 but yes lots and
lots of check so again king of the hill
you play king d6
your idea is pretty clear you are sick
of checks he don't want checks anymore
and yeah it is so many moves that you
can do wrong so it is very important
that if you are not cancelling if you
are playing around with your King you
gotta keep it's like you have to always
be focused always find the best move all
right
to anyone who is asking about Queen d1
checks like in these positions if the
king is on d8 Queen d1 check does not
work because of Queen d7 okay
so let's not do that check Queen ouch
black wins immediately King d6 Queen D
one doesn't work because we take that
guy yummy yummy
um so yes you're correct if true Thank
You alpha or I guess Oliver please
correct me if you take if you exchange
the Queen stamp or black sorry cap black
just automatically wins I mean almost
eat some pawns give it a bunch of checks
makes five Queens well only four Queens
all right so King these eggs pretty much
only move for white to try is to take on
d5 right because no checks you got to
create some rules for chick yeah thank
you Gor Kim you take on b5 you have
something to do is to give check or
attacking this guy now we give a check
right there now we give another check
keep in mind if King goes to be two we
have Queen c6 as well stopping all
checks again you can't really go back
cuz of that so let's say we got this
King goes to h4 Queen see for now black
white King is the one who is under
tremendous attack right if is you okay
I think oh sorry sorry alpha I knew
there was Oliver in my class you are
ranch there we go
ouch my bad okay it is kind of king of
the hill almost there right
okay so Quincy for you can't do it stop
it to the Queen because I can just pick
your work up or take your queen F for I
guess possible but you don't really have
any checks see if I was taken deep I was
taken a five is taken so that's why it's
pretty good in the game whose mum put G
for and after Queen D for he resigned
Queen is super centralized that there
are zero checks or can't give me any
check queens can't give me any check and
now queen of two is coming too so this
was a very interesting game one of my
like big-time favorites it's a very
interesting game on how you just keep
your king in the center and I like the
games that are out of the box and are
just challenging me to use my creativity
and don't have to just be bound to play
like just yeah so I really like this
game one of my all-time favorites it's a
great game hope you guys enjoyed it too
I will see you in a few minutes for the
games of the week have fun
[Music]
you